[Musique]
et bien mesdames et messieurs nous
allons prendre place pour la deuxième
partie de ce match je vous demande donc
de tenir chaleureusement alberto david
et laurent frayssinet oui donc alors
dans quelle partie du las cette première
partie donc on va voir maintenant le
match
la première partie le vainqueur de cette
partie encore trouvé le match donc c'est
la troisième place le podium qui se joue
sur ce match donc c'est à laurent
frayssinet avec les blancs donc on l'a
si vous entendez vous levez la main
voilà donc c'est bon dans nos rangs des
quatre voilà donc c'est parti donc des
quatre câbles et fils ou la wii va il
ajouté
une estonienne voilà il le fait oui on
avait dit il avait déjà fait à l'aller
stand yens normal là c'est la variété
classique de l'établissement qu'il a
déjà joué c'est lui ou je suis plus on
en avait eu au moins 80 des grandes
variantes avec le couffo étroit qui
avait été jouée par larsen à l'époque
dans les années 70 c'est donc laissons
bien c'était son goût favori il faut et
3 caractérisé rhône ou par ce coup
j'essaie tout g7 qui est développé à
l'est
oui contrairement à l'ouest pn qu'eric
est voulu se développent de ce côté là
donc à l'ouest à l'ouest
voilà donc ici il est développé à l'aise
il estime l'analyste indienne indian
parce qu'en fait au début des jeux il y
avait pas le rock en fait et donc les
indiens larry parc aliens ont trouvé
souvent le coup g6 et suivi le roi
faisait le rock à la main ils venaient
en g7 à la main donc c'est pour ça que
étonnant parce que l'europe n'existait
pas on ne pouvait pas passer le roi
comme ça mais il avait compris déjà que
c'est bien de mettre le roi sur le côté
mais c'était il ya longtemps c'était il
ya très longtemps
il faut rappeler que le jeu d'échecs a
quand même
mille cinq cent mille cinq cents ans
d'histoire
mais ces sondages mais on peut dire à
peu près que 5 600 ans de l'histoire
moderne avec les pièces oui en
déplacement actuel puisque c'est dans
les années 14,150 15 sans que le
déplacement définitive des pièces a été
établi avec les changements du
déplacement du vizir celle qui est
devenue la dame donc qui est une pièce à
courte portée
voilà retour ça c'est l'avant alors
grand classique un grand classique la
variante davance au centre avec des cinq
attaques ici voilà cavaliers attention
voilà le plan estime pierre delwart b4
s'est cassé 5 car les c4 ont fait ça ça
c'est le plan blanc royaume et nato
anciens et on essaie de pénétrer après
sur la sur le voilà et les noir essayer
de forcer le coup f5 et à noël cette
jolie attaques sur les le roi décide
d'attaquer de ce côté là voilà du côté
de l'ex-roi journée toutes ses flèches
beaucoup de flèches c'est de jouer comme
ça et des fois même de jouer ensuite f4
un nom de bloquer oui puis j'essaie je
sais que c'est très simple quand on peut
puis des fois même si trois temps le
rock est fait et puis si l'école et ma
joie je crois souvent mais c'est le
moment pour fausser 8 de boom d'observer
sacrifier et pour faire maths c'est le
fameux coup de fischer comme tu disais
tout à l'heure oui oui alors departed
attaques des partis d'attac pour le
joueur noir un plan simple attaque sur
les leroy donc on boit on voit bien que
l'idée elle est là mais bizarrement les
blancs en différé le le petit rock
alors peut-être qu'ils pourront faire
grand roque peut-être je sais pas si si
ça n'a pas déjà vu alors h3 c'est une
idée aussi de de jouer l'idée de jouer
g4 pour contrer là pour contrer
l'attaqué des noirs mais maintenant tout
de suite non bernard un pion puis on
prend puis on prend puis on prend sa
péremption
mais ils sauront et c'est un pion doublé
voilà oui mais ouverture la colonne âge
qui appuient le rock c'est vrai que
cette attention attention j'ai quatre là
est trop dangereux ces ouvertures de la
colonne h
on attaque le chasseur devient chasse et
on attaque avant que le roi ait donné
son adresse
oui alors j'en profite pour saluer
jérôme hébert de crillon qui organise
l'open international qui donne des clubs
de gironde eux les plus actifs à
l'international au moins d'août depuis
de nombreuses années depuis très
longtemps donc le de crayon très actif
créé par des anciens du collège de créon
et willow ryu et oni cipal le père
loriot
même mes classes les gérants berlin et
qui ont joué des tournois du collège à
l'époque est d'ailleurs présent
aujourd'hui à noter que le vainqueur le
tournoi et on crée on était qualifiés
mais qui malheureusement il s'est
désisté peine quelques semaines qui
s'est tellement c'était cette année ce
gars est bien c'est romane marathon non
c'est pas ma ratz était que je sais plus
et un ouzbek je crois enfin c'était un
grand maître d'un pays de l'est comme ça
basis même d'asie centrale d'asie bon
alors la place voilà donc il y quand il
s'appelait exactement je sais plus son
nom mais enfin voilà il était il était
ok pour venir et puis finalement dernier
moment jean fin mars finalement il s'est
désisté ou début avril
et je crois que j ai fait appel je crois
alberto david pour le remplacer voilà
donc en tant que vainqueur du tournoi
crayon il était qualifié comme
d'ailleurs l'été yoann benita vainqueur
de l'open d amélie qui lui a confirmé
et bienvenue donc cette position avec un
pion à rire et le pion typique arriérés
en f3 ce pion qui est à l'arrière de ses
copains pions sur une colonne ouverte à
l'ennemi est donc ce pion va être
attaquables pressure abl donc vous
remettre un cavalier ici
oui mais à condition de reprendre une
pièce ceux ci ont si on le prend
oui mais il n'est pas prenable ce serait
un très bon cavalier très bons cavaliers
avec la menace tout simplement comme il
faut et ensuite
voila voila il menace précis n'est
appuyé sur le sur la cible sur le coup
comme tour à 3 me paraît très passif et
je vois pas d'autres coûts ou alors si
donc 6e puis ensemble ça fera un pion de
plus d'erreurs pour les noirs dans
qu'avantage noir notions complexes
pas facile d'évaluer ce genre
d'opposition estonienne c'est souvent
des débats extrêmement compliqué en
partie lente laurent partie rapide ça
doit être pire que pire pire que tout a
évalué à noter qu'il ya une menace tout
de suite
pour nous c'est fou quand j'ai quatre à
de simples allégations
j'ai quatre dames mérite d'être en f2
protégé par la tour obligé partir en
alors comment défendre g4g cas très
difficile à défendre parce que on
attaque deux fois donc on peut prendre
deux fois angers 4 avec les noirs pour
capter le pion à son mal oui le coup et
6,7 le coup et si c'est un coup très
fort pour 2006 le ku'damm f6 le coût de
la même si c'est un coup très fort
comment faire avec une petite menace
tactique colonel et wheeler ici soit
avec le fou soi-même d'ailleurs avec le
cavaly leblanc s'est écarté les
principes fondamentaux n'a pas terminé
son développement il est en retard de
développement
un retard important un cavalier qui est
pas heureux en f1 un cavalier plus des
dans son camp - il est heureux il
l'aiment bien aller se promener dans les
prairies adverse d'un souci ils vont
contre les cavaliers pour aller brouter
les pions des choses dans le terrain
adversaire fou 3 tout simplement il faut
sortir son jeu jouable pour
contre-attaquer champions juste il faut
sortir le fou et empêcher cette 79 alors
il est en train de réfléchir
quelle est la meilleure case pour sortir
ce fou moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à le
mettre en g3 de manière à contrôler le
cavalier g61 contrôler les deux cases du
cavalier g6 en jouant fujitsu et surtout
ou 3 il pourrait y avoir qu'un voyage
théâtre voilà je veux jeter un oeil sur
ses cavaliers mais peut-être qu'il a une
autre idée il peut aussi avoir l'idée
fouet trois pour jouer tour h5 et
attaquer le pion gsm voilà oui mais donc
il est en train de peser tout ça
attention oui surtout sur fou et roya
cavaliers h 4 s4 et tu peux pas qu'ils
attaquent le pion f3 et qui empêche donc
le coup donc il joue le coup normal on
va dire entre guillemets pouget 3 trop
de flèches ont effectué tous les trois
ont touché 3 ton idée cavaliers cadre
nasbinals menace cavale et prend 1,2
d'emprunt est trop gagnant pions ou
menacent aussi cavalier j'ai deux échecs
pour des rockets droit puis reviendra en
f4 pour faire ces menaces donc c'est pas
une position facile pour pour les blancs
parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore trouvé de
le véritable amour il ya le roi ils ont
le retard développement
alors qu'est ce qui va faire qu'elle
peut faire cavalier d2 mais alors c'est
un aveu d'impuissance parce qu'il
reviendrait en dessous alors qu'il en
bien oui mais attention anderau cage
près cavaliers j'ai deux échecs ou
valeron ouais mais surtout il appuie
aprilia dollars sur le coup donc cavalli
h2 comme ça sur cavalli ville de l'échec
il va peut-être jouer je vais peut-être
jouer faux point f 3 mais je fais un
petit rocco la main il ya peut-être joué
fou prend f3 je pense qu'il va rester
jouer point f3 mais à ce moment là
bref trois c'est vraiment malheureux
comme un coin parce que quand la cloche
de pour des le fond blanc lequel georges
deviendrait très faible très bas ici il
n'y a pas vraiment de choix
bon c'est pas c'est oui non si quand
même et on s'en remet aux rites les
noirs sont quand même un peu mieux
non il ya empêcher l'initiative de la
nada donc c'est le seul coup cavaliers
h2 pour regarder le matériel alors lis
pas ce que veut dire ah c'est pas
vraiment pas si le cavalier sur la
première hausse sur la seconde ne sont
que les cavaliers défensif alors ne sont
pas des belles bêtes
une entente est un joueur d'attaqué
solution pour les blancs c'est de jouer
aux dames d2 et ensuite de faire fondre
en f4 de façon que sur dame prend à
pouvoir échanger
oui mais ça reste avantage noir à cause
de sommes très mauvais pour le case
blanche
oui mais attention la case f5 et faible
aussi un rond nous et on peut très bien
jouer ensuite qu'à valider un cavalier
ou 3 et 9 5 qui a quand même des
ressources là encore c'est pas gagné
c'est pas gagné
c'est encore très très compliqués à
juger même si on a le sentiment que les
noirs quand même on l'initiative ici il
semblerait quand même que les blancs est
pas une position si malsaine que ça ça
va encore tout à fait jouable du fait
que notamment cette case f5 et faible
aussi gfk très faible pour les blancs
mais lacazette 5 et aussi pour les noirs
on sait les caractéristiques des
positions fermes et cavaliers des
cavaliers trois cavaliers f5 et il sera
très beau ce qu'avait dit ici et là en
plus intercepté l'action sur la colonne
des pièces lourdes
il va être bien
que rien n'est perdu moyens on voit
train c'est technique
peut-être tout ça at il était prévu donc
un coup comme cavalier deux échecs très
bien on des rocs le roi mais c'est pas
grave on va en d2 n'y a pas de menace
ont bandé doit une fois une fois l'arbre
en d2 peut-être qu'on peut entreprendre
des rangs ces deux des attaques sur les
ailes dame pour ouvrir des lignes
s'approcher du roi non mais non ont du
mal à ou dans ce type de position à
ouvrir des lignes ainsi que les moyens
possibles c'est pas le genre de position
ont pu ouvrir des lignes parce qu'il ya
déjà des pions immobilisé ici il
faudrait tenter une rupture avec b5
oui mais une prise ici oui mais en jour
et tu vois a6b 5 en donnant un pion
ainsi on veut aller chercher le roi qui
est en vadrouille sur la case des deux
derrière il faut donner un pion oui mais
c'est pas si facile il faut donner un
pied en basque il facile parce que comme
le centre est bloqué le fou ne peut pas
participer à la taxe ça reste une
position ferme et il n'est pas sûr que
ce soit pas les blancs qui arrivait a
profité de l'ouverture des lignes donc
c'est pas facile a jugé vraiment
difficile et je le dis avec d'autant
plus de facilité que je joue souvent le
stand n est que c'est jamais celle de
savoir exactement à qui profites
ouverture des lignes vrai il faut faire
très attention et ça peut se jouer
parfois un coup tactique peut
transformer une ouverture de lignes qui
semblent favorables à une ouverture
défavorable
ça peut ces courants donc là on assiste
à un jeu de tranchées de regroupement de
calcul de cases
c'est un jeu de quasi six envoyés
pourquoi parce que essentiellement il ya
des structures ici une structure de
pions qui fait face à une autre culture
de pions et un briquet et donc on voit
qu'il ya du coup blocage et patrick
voyer je sais déjà fermé il n'y a pas de
rupture possible et donc ce sont les
cases faibles qui vont permettre de
l'éventuelle mans de faire la différence
casey 5 faible ici du côté noir et que
les blancs pourront jouer par laurent
blanc alors attention la dernière idée
des noirs allaient connu c'est de jouer
h5 pour faire une rupture justement et
ouvrir complètement la colonne f
donc c c'est l'idée et puis aussi de la
vague des dehors c'est exactement ce que
j'avais dit tout à l'heure
et puis aussi d'améliorer voilà
améliorons améliorer le canaliserait vue
vous avez vu comme il a amélioré cette
pièce ce cavalier kate et anna 6 il lui
trouve la case et g6 et pour relayer le
cavaly f4 sur la case sensible c'est la
cazelle 4 ce moment de prendre pour les
pour lui blanc alors que je crois que
j'ai déjà parlé dans un commentaire
d'une autre partie de ce thème la clé
que les grands joueurs font souvent il
ils essaient toujours d'améliorer leur
mauvaise pièce ils traînent pas des
mauvaises pièces dans la partie et ils
savent qu'une once pièce peut leur
coûter la partie
c'est bon de prendre nous parce que si
les noirs prennent avec le canon c'est
pas bon parce que les noirs prendre ici
évidemment et ça libérerait ainsi vers
le fossé le fou de vieilles puissances
africaines police et les noirs doubler
les cavaliers il faut pas libérer le fou
de cases noires des noirs qui est leur
mauvaise pièce pour l'instant attention
bon alors par contre les blancs peuvent
faire les banques
oui tu vois je les avais parlé du grand
roque dans ce type de position de
l'union n'ont pas fait des chèques donc
et on s'aperçoit qu'à ce moment là c'est
le pion rage qui a des soucis c'est
parce qu'il est arriérée lui aussi sur
la colonne ouverte
donc il ya quelques escales indiennes
comme ça qu'ils ont été joués avec
grandes robes des blancs je pense que
laurent frayssinet réfléchi deux
solutions sont faire grand roque soit
joué d'abord qu'à valider un et
cavaliers 3 mais non il fait d'abord la
mesa retard voilà on y est retardé car
l'idée un caillou trois ans n'y en avait
parlé au début de la partie de ces
possibilités d'erreurs aux acadiens
voilà donc là il a doublé les cavaliers
mais c'est quand même table dans vie
d'un là il n'y a pas grand chose à
prendre à ce cafouillage de finalement
il tient la baraque un candidat qui a la
baraka nabarra qui tient ses deux pions
importants et c'est pour ça qu'il qu'il
a fait le relais des cavaliers pour
pouvoir reprendre d'un cavalier et avoir
toujours le chantage cavaliers prendre
depuis dame price 3 pour le cas où le
blanc voudrait évacuer la colonne h très
technique c'est pour pouvoir exploiter
la colonne h les techniques allant au
niveau du temps 11 minutes
contre 13 bon c'est à peu près
équivalente petit avantage alberto david
au niveau du temps donc maintenant il
faut s'organiser pour défendre f3 et
puis non mais pour libérer le cavalier
et pour travailler sur la sho pense pas
je pense pas non je pense pas qu'il va
faire ça il va il va peut-être mettre
une tour là il va surtout joué calais
dunkerque 3 4 5 et une fois que l'ajout
de kbc qu'il a plus de problème avec est
roi voilà donc ça va très bien fait
circuler le cavalier c'est un hiver joue
contre h7
voilà donc alors il a mis il a mis la
tour en juin pourquoi pas ah oui mais
oui bien sûr parce qu'il voudra plus
tard passer par il veut passer par la f1
et il veut pas entraver les tours il va
pas entraver la loi il aura une défaite
très bien vu de la part d'alberto l'idée
qu'à aider un sans doute c'est toujours
des scènes tout de suite oui il faut
ouvrir les lignes sur les dames
maintenant comment connaît l'adresse
foutant bien placé même si le fou de
contrôle oui on connaît l'adresse dur du
roi blanc
maintenant si j'arrive à ouvrir des
lignes ensuite jours les joueurs des
joueurs si j'arrive à ouvrir des lignes
sur lequel dame je vais pénétrer mes
pièces lourdes
j'ai créé des problèmes d'insurrection
mais le plan c'est quand même qu'à
valider un que les 3 4 5 qui paraît
quand même assez fort et les blancs
pourront aussi doubler les cavaliers
qualité d'accueil ou trois lignes noires
oui oui tout à fait et à la fin c'est
pas sûr que ça soit pas le pion à j-7
qui pose plus problème au noir quelque
chose et c'est pas facile de juger ses
positions s'il parce que les deux
joueurs maintenant des thèmes des thèmes
qui se dessine bien alors laurent
frayssinet réfléchi peut-être beaucoup à
4 au 6 mai mais das casas immobile de
cavaliers en c3 oui comment faire pour
garder le contrôle pour freiner la
l'ouverture des lignes sur les dames
vaisselle menace évidemment mais bon
pour l'instant lié trois fois info
qu'elle s'est lui quatre cavaliers c3 et
fougueux attention autant le rend facile
puisque deux minutes vingt il a
maintenant trois minutes presque deux
heures de retard il s'est fait grignoter
ça va faire
grignoter trois minutes de retard ça y
est en plein dans trois minutes de
retard
pour laurent frayssinet 1 c'est pas
facile hein c'est pas facile les plans
sont compliquées il faut calculer donc
là moi je
il faut qu'il réfléchisse sur vise à
faire de sao a faut faire confiance aux
grands maîtres dans ces situations là
c'est extrêmement compliqué voilà les
noirs vont essayer eu d'attaqué voilà à
6 dans la tranquille à il a joué food et
1 il a joué foulée m pour prendre des
mesures kanza qu'entre les futurs
rupture a oui d'accord il laisse le fou
la défense des droits et il veut ça y
est il a joué à 10 5
parce cavalli et les six cavalli c3 en
défense du côté droit
voilà ça alors ça c'est très fin un ebay
label compréhension de ça se mange sans
faim du jeu moi je suis toujours
impressionné par la manière dont ils oui
quand ils perçoivent le jeu évidente il
a une pensée à travailler belles cases
pour le cavalier alors évidemment fougue
et 5,6 car il prend pions prend et et on
a deux est attaqué par la tour et puis
le duo b5 c5 devient redoutable pour
ouvrir les lignes sur le roi surtout pas
prendre là il faut pas prendre bien sûr
il faut bouger ce cavalier ou le
défendre avec un an et trois mois et de
3,1 me laisse froid sans défense oui
mais comment il faut enlever revenir un
peu pâle on arrive à sortir de cavaliers
on peut voir et si le sol us voilà il a
pas de gaz pas de quelqu'un tout à
l'heure il partait avec prise et antoine
et ankhel grave alliés sont contrôlés
ici ici par l'adam la part la tour dans
la tour la part le pion tout est
contrôlé le pire mais penske pas non
plus à cause du pion et qu'il la dame
aussi ici il ya encore le pion par des
combinés ce cavalier complètement cerné
donc il est il peut pas bouger il est
immobilisé il est beau ce qu'il est dans
le camp adverse mais il
donc il va bientôt jouer vite immobilisé
sur le droit sur la colonnade assez
bizarre comme ceux qui ne croyaient pas
joli mais peut-être que l'idée de m'en
faut signer c'est peut-être un sac et si
on le revend une visée sur le roi un
peut-être qu'un jour il y aura cavaliers
province et wii et wii et des cinq des
six échecs attention ah oui un jour
attention demain là donc il faut que le
père tôt david de fasse attention à
cette menace la toujours trois minutes
guillaume et 3 alors que peut faire le
berthod maintenant donc que c'est pas y
voyez que son initiative bon certes il a
eu un peu 17 ce côté là mais finalement
il n'a rien retiré de concret l'idée de
four b3 cessé de jouer à trois puis fou
à deux et pas de rupture puisque le pion
à ne trouve pas de pions pour ouvrir une
ligne peut pas d'ouvrir le dicible droit
3 x 2 et b pour pour que le pion ne
puisse pas jouer à 5 à 4 ah oui assène à
quatre attaques le fouet à 3 à 3,3 en
ligne ou pour les ici sur bien sûr bien
sûr donc il faut il faut pas permettre
fulham à 17,4 en jour at on prend
d'abord le cavalier on prend d'abord le
fou le fou dans ce cas là voilà dans ce
cas là mais c'est ce serait le thème
d'essayer d'ouvrir avec le pion bien sûr
donc là pour plusieurs raisons et nous
p3 un petit fou qui lorgneront et on
voit bien que laurent aura du mal à
aller là parce que boom
on peut y voir des sacrifices ici voire
même des maths
voilà bull idée d'où l'idée a joué à six
voilà h6 comme ça le pire là on protège
avec l'offre est défendue par le faut
maintenant il faut faire un sacrifice de
dynamitage same dream pièces lourdes
pour la qualité épiant il faut
s'affirmer on veut que ça en ferme le
fou oui il faudra jouer tous rage de
tora chain plus tard dans la partition
n'arrivons finale se fout il devra jouer
fou et 6 fou des 8es x 5 pour avoir de
l'air est attaqué dans le camp ennemi
parce que la voyez comme il est dominé
par ses propres pions
complètement c'est pour l'instant c'est
du bois - or ce qu'on appelle du bois
mort
une caisse qui joue pas du tout se fout
de ce fou g7 l'a14 où c'est mieux qu'à
trois c'est mieux qu'à 3 comme ça il
faut que le gars prenne sa décision
qu'il soit ils prennent soin bref ce
chemin et qu'il laisse le lecavalier
puissant sur la case c4 c'est une belle
case si animalière 1
s'ils jouent ça évidemment l'écurie est
là présent le cavalier une belle case en
c4 très belle case la case animalière
effectivement devant olympio et demi est
inattaquable par un pur latéral
finalement finalement là je préfère
l'opposition blanche comme ça sourit
parce qu'il a neutralisé
il a neutralisé les ruptures nous a
complètement neutralisé les en tournant
alors attention quand même montant 7
minutes 30 c9 unis comme on voit bien
d'ailleurs que ça s'est un peu inversés
puisque il prend plus de temps lui
retourne nom d'entreprise et plus de
deux minutes d'écart bryza il a pris
pour avoir une cible la colonne b pour
avoir une colonne de travail la pologne
colonies si voix la colonne de travail
donc peut-être que je vous tends vide
mais s'il fait tomber 8 et non pas tour
c'est là parce qu'ils perdraient +161 ce
qui peut être content quand même puisque
après fou prend à 6 ans que je vous fous
des scènes qui est celle là ça va plus
non il faut pas donner du matériel
inconsidérément donc à une fille quand
même il le fait si alors qu'elle et libé
quelle est l'idée parce que il veut
venir en b 4 voilà pour mener en mai
calais pour venir en d4 après et pour
venir en aide à tout y est comme dit
notre ami alberto n'ont d'avenir le
mastic chatouiller chattaoui je pense
qu'il veut exploiter la colonne b avant
que commence à se faire avant que la
dame parte et que les tours et le temps
de défendre b2 donc qui donne le pion à
6 d'ailleurs il ne le prend pas il
verrouille il en ne la chante pas il
refuse to b 4 il passera pas oui
puisqu'il y avait tourné calme si
complexe iturbe 8
ce petit complexe issifou étions qui se
poseraient protège meeting empêche toute
pénétration
voilà nos amis voilà maintenant ils
ramènent la dame pour attaquer les cases
noires qui sont faibles un peu voyez
donc là il y aura sans doute cavaliers
et des seins alors on interdit à faire
l'arrivée de la dame
alors est ce que les blancs maintenant
peuvent pas lancer leurs plans et
cavaliers d un cahier où trois cas les
f-5 avec quand même un boom
c'est ce qu'il fait il le fait c'est
pire il est tombé 4 alors là maintenant
les incitons tradition en eau
attention les sacrifices peuvent payer 3
il va venir en scène que l'on en fait
signer avec pression sur l'a6 attention
si ça pénètre ça va être les marques ont
des présentations en sacrifice à il peut
y avoir aussi damas cinq tours prend ses
quatre échecs et dame prend 1,4 à jude à
memphis aux menaces et aux combes 3 1
bien sûr il peut aussi triplé oui oui
attention il va tripler
il veut revenir ici le triplet donner
une qualité il va donner une qualité non
c'est pas possible il peut pas wynn
holmes il pourra mais alors surtout
reprend il faudra pas que lecavalier
parte parce que si lecavalier par sur
qui on prend voilà il à triple play
c'est à dire la sas est parti par là bas
il a triplé bon et j'ai une belle partie
belle partie d'attaqué la faune jamais
prendre ici parce qu'alors on prendrait
du piola ça soit vous deviendrez énorme
ont regardé à ta strophes donc jamais
jamais jamais prendre sur la case f4
d'antan pas tant que les dom et ils sont
là en tout cas donc partie d'attac
attention au 7 rue dynamitage un jour
alors attention imaginons que la tour
joue ici et bien tour en dessous donc ça
marche pas elle cavaliers toujours ça va
mais sinon après puis on prend
évidemment il ya prise en b1 donc à
temps voilà typiquement là on a coupé
les tours donc faut faire très attention
oui un très joli coup de laurent
frayssinet ce dernier coup puisque la
menace est simplement dans le mail adam
simplement des joues la dame par exemple
en c1 ici et hop on défend la vallée
mais je l'avais dit ça y est pas le fou
mais c'est d'autre côté voilà l'a pas
vue sur le voilà voilà voilà
je comprends bien ça y est ça y est le
fameux d'in aménas dynamitage dont je
parlais la pièce non
la bavure et oui le coup fin avec
quelque chose de malsain dans le fait
qu'ils couper la liaison des tours et
lui couper la liaison de tours c'est ce
qu'on l'a vu tout de suite et j'ai été
braquée sur le fou mais il y avait aussi
le pion voilà donc il a pris le pion et
voilà bon tu es obligé de jouer un coup
nos défenses là et je vais dans ce qu'il
doit pas trop aimé ça ce qu'ils voient
pas les louanges du fou sur la simple
position qu'elle est maintenant le roi
n'a pas d'abri vraiment sur un lac un
pion pour le défendre les pièces 5
minutes 10 contre 8 minutes alors là
c'est alberto david qui prend une option
pour la troisième place à 5 maintenant
naturel à manassas quatre ans à 4 et
ouverture des lignes ça y est les les
ouvertures de lignes qui n'existaient
pas avec le pion à tout à l'heure
bah les terrains existent le thème
arrive comme quoi des condamnés seule
adresse
on peut avoir de la visite secret qui a
pris des cours de la vie oui c'est pas
mal ça oui ce qui est le cas dans cet
effectif garanti
oh là là quelle erreur de l'ons fait
signer car il a couru un maintien à
l'erreur il avait une position assez
mais c'est vrai que c'est des parties
rapides donc oui maintenant le salut de
7 minutes 30 le coup à 4 va arriver avec
force l après tour à trois lames nancy
ce qui est à l'épaule paris et oui il ya
la dame ainsi ça va ça va mal ça va très
mal
il protège et protège et à 4 oui ils
protègent les laisser sur place
non il m'a pris du tout prix la tour un
tour pendable échec dans le kent en mai
chez huawei
mais il peut encore sortir par damas un
remake
quoi qu'il arrive il y aura un pion pas
ses protégés en c5 très puissant oui ce
pion l' espion qui change ici après ce
pion est un non seulement il est en plus
ouais j'aime pas ce problème puisqu'il
ya cinq pions contre 4 c'est juste sur
le reste de l'échiquier c'est fait et ce
pion est une arme qui peut gagner à la
scion l attention aussi à des plans
comme publicis 15 h catherine frot et le
pm3 qui lui est fragile alors dans la
position blanche s'est écroulé va
s'écrouler petit à petit la valeur a vu
le coup tant qu'un tel coup malheureux
bien sûr il voyait qu'ils défendent et
le fou c4 est aussi à ce fou moyens oui
oui il a oublié le pion et donc après
maintenant c'est finalement il n'aura
pas réussi c'est en route pour les
trains tournoi laurent frayssinet le
second prix hommage plus c'est pas du
sourire de retard bientôt c'est
difficile avait nommé damascène je
refuse à damas m ça va pas du tout
puisque selon damaseb simplement
d'amsterdam et en échange d'un programme
fou prend et ensuite si on prend les
trois échecs et le fouet tard où le fou
il perdu non non il n'ya plus donc voilà
dans la position et blanc difficile il
se fait opérer la phyto graciant depuis
lors il est bloqué il peut même pas
sortir la dame et donc il est obligé de
subir le clouage par des halls alberto
joue quasiment un coup de coude attentes
laissant freyssinet dans ces problèmes
oh là là où il donne un intéressant oui
il donne n'a pas vu ça alberto l'idée
c'est surtout reprend ont fait par
exemple vous prend et derrière on
récupère la tourbe et 8 donc ça fait
deux tours pour la dame de coeur pour la
dame a way intéressant mais on n'a pas
du tout envisagé sa 7e liberto la vue
petites tactiques l'avc dit alberto il
ya prise avec échec aliments il s'est
arrêté là il s'est arrêté après leur
échec et s'arrêter après son échec qui
seront jamais a lancé oui
sinon la ja doublage il y avait le choix
pour le moment il faut prendre la dame
et oui il faut prendre la dame on n'a
pas le choix c'est obligé en appréciant
fou prend on peut même pas reprendre la
tour puisque sinon si on si on prenait
la tombe de mon père sinon oui et non
c'est aussi on peut tout simplifier en
fait c'est c'est incroyable la richesse
est mal à l'eau du jeu d'échecs qui le
pleurent mais lorsqu'on oublie un seul
petit détail un peu le choix alberto il
faut parler des blancs ont récupéré le
pion mêmes ils ont même pas s'éloigner
incroyable en deux coups mais oui la
tactique est bientôt servillo d'alberto
david roy suite est une erreur
monumentale il était beaucoup mieux il a
juste et réfléchie tout reprendre un
échec donc les blancs peuvent pas
prendre mais non mais non parce qu'il a
il fallait qu est ce qui se passe oui il
fallait simplement qu'il prenne ce pied
en mai 3 il va prendre la tour dont il
peut jouer avec dame contre deux tours
mais deux tours c'est fort en dessous
avec eux oui avec hamas est là avec deux
pièces passive ne le sera pas et rouge
et sel et une fois que le tout autant
mais vu notre tour vient bessette et à
lecavalier ya le fou derrière mes pièces
en passive où l'alors donc quand mon
avis il n'a pas trop le choix là alors
falloir qu'ils donnent ils devaient
jouer simplement beneddra comme quoi il
devait jouer à prend b3 mais bien sûr
ils aiment plis fier et autres options
possibles avant son fiancé 5 donc la
finale
l'espoir changea de camp qu'est ce qui
peut faire comme bachar ja dame qu'est
ce qui peut faire
qu'est ce qui peut faire oui oui c'est
ce que je te disais tout à l'heure c'est
coeur simplement bécaud échec et la
tactique bien régler les problèmes c'est
extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé qui
leur a d'ailleurs il est en train de
descendre autant oh là là bien
recommencer dont un sommet cela
complètement raté ce souci mais quel
coup au moral quand on est une position
gagner tranquillement et qu'il abandonne
aulas lors incroyable alors j'ai
absolument qu'on
bien jolie victoire de laurent précise
encore un coup tactique il dévoile une
attaque sur la dame puisqu'il y avait eu
parties nulles la première partie c'est
donc laurent frayssinet qui remporte le
match
oui alors bon il ya un abandon alors
peut-être à leur tour tu peux nous
expliquer pourquoi tu as vendu
exactement c'est à dire que normalement
je déduis 30 saddam va récupérer soit il
aura les deux tours pour la dame il a
rentré avec succès
soit on aura l égalité matérielle et
toutes mes pièces elles sont enfermées
de ce côté là
c'est bien ce qu'on analyse et en cabine
donc c'est ce pion à caso coup en fait
tu as dû réfléchir quand tu as joué tant
qu'ouvrage suite à une espèce d'une
sorte de preuve d'attentes un coût de
près ce que ce que ge wang en fait tu as
juste vu tout reprendre d'armes échec
donc c'est pas possible de le faire en
fait tout simplement lensois de bouger
de fou et éventuellement pour mettre le
cavalier ici donc je voulais prendre
s'appliquer une pièce je pensais qu'il
allait être là j'avais vu des idées on
peut pas le voir parce que le résultat
et le résultat est marqué gérer la
diagonale pour enfin jouer le français
voilà donc peut-être laurent petit un
petit commentaire donc c'est passé
davantage d'un camp à l'autre en
quelques cool mais disons que pour
l'ouverture je pensais que je sais pas
ce qu'on pense alberto mais je pensais
me ma position en tout cas été quand
j'ai pris en c4 que j'ai fait car je
pensais ma position est stratégiquement
gagnant que jusqu'à jouer précis parce
que vont en général les pièces à les
droits sont pas très actif de noir et je
pense à un bon contrôle de cette case
est bon j'ai gaffé excluant évidemment
et
et après alberto même si je pense en
fait c'est pas facile à gagner mais
d'après mieux jouer je pense mais bon en
général je pense que c'est je pense que
c'est le voilà donc bon mais voilà
terminé donc on peut encore applaudir
les deux joueurs
voilà en fait si les gagne la troisième
place de ce grand prix est bien que tout
à l'heure avec deux heures bien nous
incitant à la grande finale se drape
d'échec 2007
[Musique]
oh